this is what we were giving out today
the qur'an and I encourage everyone all
the not yet Muslims even the Muslims
will haven't open up the car ah we have
it here in English and this is something
tell us what kind of I'm here with
Sheikh Abdullah what kind of impact did
this have on your life this book I just
had a huge impact on my life my soul on
you know really realizing I mean like my
main concern was when becoming Muslim if
God was telling me how to live my life I
wanted to know if there was a manual he
was telling me do this do that or
telling me more about myself on things
that I knew but really couldn't really
didn't know in totality and tell me my
reality of this life and what's gonna
happen after I wanted to know about it
so that's the impact it had on me really
tell us now for newcomers to the
religion even some who are the
old-timers I was picking up this book
you're someone who is another academic
you went to had a formal education in
this Deen and Islam but now you have
nowadays people picking up the book and
making up or we want to prevent people
from picking up the book and kind of
making their own there's some things in
here that are just straightforward but
you can go deeper exactly you know like
cool law I'd say God is one the absolute
the eternal it's pretty straight for but
you can go even deeper down but so
people pick up the crowd and then they
get into some areas and it becomes kind
of dangerous can you say right tell us
you know the prevent something like that
what is the the proper way that the the
Quran is interpreted there inveterate
interpreted so people can prevent making
these huge blunders yes man that's a
real good question it's a fine line it's
it's more of like how to approach the
Quran
cuz I mean many times you know we think
that we can just give the non-muslim
Acronis they read it and leave them on
the leave them to read it which is good
in essence but there are going to be
some verses that may seem contradictory
and that further it requires further
education further
a seeking consultation from people of
knowledge that have and of study the
Texas self and what you're alluding to
is generally is a issue of
interpretation interpretation as we know
the word text comes from context right
so there is a context to the text that
you read right so who Allahu Ahad it
says full say that Allah is one so it
was definitely a lot telling the proper
source on to say that but the general
the generality of Allah being one is
something that's paramount to the
religion of Islam so there are verses
that are very clear-cut straight to the
point there's no room even for
interpretation and there are some verses
that have a heavy context to it that
would require one to look at the history
or was a reason for it being revealed
what is the meaning of the word in
Arabic how do we interpret that word
that coincides with the spirit of the
religion that may coincide with the
Sunnah of the Prophet sallallaahu a
southern peace and blessings be upon him
so not every verse is just clear cut yes
it means that and that's it and I'm
going to practice my religion therefore
there's a Sunnah to show the a proper
interpretation of it and if there are
some verses that may require a certain
practice that may not be in this one it
requires scholarship and that process in
and of itself is in the Quran so we see
in the beginning of the chapter of Imran
it talks about that that there are
scholars that understand some verses and
some of them may be ambiguous for the
ambiguous verses you go to the people of
knowledge to find out their process of
interpretation and those scholars are
the Prophet peace must be upon him the
people that were around him as we may
know like the disciples and companions
and then the generations that follow
them the three generations primarily
that followed them their interpretation
is an interpretive method that has a
chain of narration that goes back to the
Prophet he's investing the opponent and
if someone says why would God Almighty
have some some verses in there that are
ambiguous is that what you're referring
referring to the the Iowa God Almighty
is saying there are verses in here that
are clear to the point and some are
ambiguous yes sir
if someone says why would God have
ambiguous verses why would he do that
well see the thing is it's ambiguous
from our perspective hmm right
the ambiguity is not with God but it's
God answering the question
it's God giving a an answer to a
situation the problem encountered right
so that requires some investigation from
the person that wants to study it so it
just requires some investigation and
upon that investigation with they were
obviously oh that is the reason that
that has been revealed as such can you
make an example like let's say someone
picks up the Constitution or any kind of
book now some things that I mean not I
mean we cannot equate anything like with
the the Koran but let's say you get into
finance not everybody is a finance
expert and has that in the Quran like
inheritance right you need an expert in
that area there are other things in the
Quran that you need to go to someone who
spent and dedicated their life in this
area to be able to explain that not just
any layman can pick up the same way you
can't just pick up you know the
Constitution some things you might
understand but you need someone who
who's an expert in this area that can go
ahead and explain it right definitely
definitely would then they make that
examples of people know yeah it
definitely when they're in any type of
ancient manuscript there may be some
linguistic maybe some linguistic nuances
that are important for someone to
further dip into whether it's linguistic
whether it's contextual so when the
Quran it's all of them so finding out
which one is it linguistic when allah
subhanho wa taala like when he says in
the quran allah took a loot about alba -
mobile i do not eat riba do not consume
rebound
why does Allah say : as opposed to tough
wolf told needs to take tuck or means to
eat so why do I say eat here why do I
say - move off and he says well often
like more than one time or or or
exponential amount of times why did he
mention that to show the danger and the
the wretchedness of interest right even
when we look at the word RIBA means to
increase but he uses that word even when
talking about vegetation and talking
about the seed right when you talk about
it swells and it increases so all of
that has a linguistic implication behind
it which further enables one to give a
ruling
whether permissible information or
further enables one to show the
wretchedness of something so there has a
linguistic a linguistic element behind
it a couple more points you know we can
give can you give us a couple examples
we were talking about earlier one of
them and not mention one more will
conclude so this can really hit home
with many people who again might open up
the Koran and they see in here that all
it talks about in toxicants but then you
get hit with this a lot well we
marijuana is not like alcohol so this
would be a correct or incorrect way of
interpreting the crime right it's a
person to go ahead and say what are the
things that yeah I mean everyone first
came Muslim Agathe you know Italy is
from the earth so it's allowed we can
smoke it right a law says who Olivia
Hanukkah lucuma field of the jamia he is
the one that's created everything on
this earth for you logically it's making
sense what he's saying kind somewhere
right let go means for you mean that
it's for you to indulge and embark upon
you can use it so why can't I get water
import import on my cell phone or why
can't I put a blow-dryer into the water
while I'm taking a shower I mean there
are certain things that yes it's there
but you have to use it appropriately for
that which benefits you and once you
call them across to share which bit
which which fulfils an Islamic objective
right so when one smokes weed for no
medical purposes it does not fulfill an
Islamic objective of maintaining the
health and maintaining ultimately the
religion because one will be intoxicated
an intoxication is talked about in the
Quran in terms of liquor and liquor is
impermissible in this process is what we
call PS and analogy see that process is
a Scholastic process if one doesn't
study that they may say okay smoking
weed is impermissible taking you know
handlebars or ecstasy is permissible
because Allah has created it so I'm
indulging upon it I'm using it well that
indulgence how is it permissible does it
have parameters or does it not so that's
where this comes into play of looking
into this text and seeing how we
properly apply those verses those
possibly ambiguous verses and another
thing something may be ambiguous to you
but not ambiguous to me why is it not in
biggest
anymore because I've studied it it's
ambiguous to you because you haven't
studied it you just read it and took it
for face value and just went along with
it but when you look maybe flip a couple
of pages or ask a question you felt you
realize that you were thinking total
opposite of them and this goes with our
top of a proper interpretation giving
the car on its right yes right now that
you come at it with a sincere heart and
not just that but you come at it with
knowledge you come at it interpreted the
way it's meant to be interpreted right
exactly so interpretation itself has its
parameters because some can say okay
your interpretation is based off of your
experience you came from a rough
background and your interpretation is to
be rough with non-muslims your
interpretation is to be rough my
interpretation is to be easy with with
Muslims or with non-muslims
that's because of your background even
your personality your psychology will
cause you to interpret it in a way that
befits or what you think is befitting to
Islam right I mean I give a handshake to
her brother and he was like I struck and
he said brother and it's not with Sofie
you know the possum said she's not
softness anything accepted it perfects
it he was trying to say that boy you
can't shake hands hard man why are you
being so hard on the people I said
that's because you know he was in a mood
of being soft being easy but then you
know there's other portions of Islam
where it speaks about manhood it speaks
about being a protector speaks about
being honorable right Aslam covers both
of those angles and aspects but for you
this for you to interpret it interpreted
without any process or method that has
been sanctioned that's where it can be
problematic because if we say
interpretation is open for anyone we
will have another sect as we see with
even Isis right now right we see with
even people saying that homosexual
homosexuality in Islam is okay it's
valid no we don't say that homosexuality
is allowed in Islam but can one someone
be a home Muslim homosexual yes we don't
say because he's homosexual he's outside
the fold of Islam no we say that it's a
major sin but we don't say that they are
not Muslim right so if someone says
homosexuality is okay not wearing hijab
as a Muslim woman I say it's okay
Islamically that's what we have a
problem
where do you say it's okay that's where
he
where's your proof in Islam she'll bring
a hadith or she'll bring you know a
verse in the Quran and it should
interpret it a certain way that's where
we really look at okay your method of
interpretation is it something that is
sanctioned like I mentioned before this
may be quite controversial you know but
longish is in the Quran we talked about
the process on you talked about marriage
he said funky whoo Matabele come in
Aneesa mana wahoo laughs water back fill
em testify them time to do for what I
did a nomadic at a medical last month on
SAS about Mary from women to three or
four how many does it doesn't add it to
be Shaykh 89 so someone may say we can
marry nine in Islam the process of them
had nine during his lifetime right so we
can marry nine and we're supposed to
follow the Sunnah where did you get that
yeah he read open the open the Quran
their losses it very clearly funk you my
father can be said month at what to
Lhasa what robot what means and it came
in in or it can mean or or it can mean
other than if you don't study the method
of interpretation you may come out and
say it's okay to marry nine but when we
look into some of the process of them
that's not the case so interpretation
does have a scholastic process if one
does not understand a Scholastic process
they will use their intellect to
interpret authoritative text and that's
where a lot of problems have arisen in
Islam
you brought this point up and we'll
finish with this it's very interesting
and about the having multiple families
is this opinion are they both valid is
this where you have the example of the
interpretation being something that both
are within the realm of proper to
interpretation where one is saying that
the preferable is that you have up to
you not one but more than one two three
or four that you have
more for families and the other
interpretation is saying that no one is
preferable which now which one when you
have two different interpretations yeah
man no when it comes to interpretation
the validity of interpretation that's
where we have to look at what was his
what method did he use to interpret it
like that so someone would say what
means and and therefore it's okay so we
were just look at the Quran and say wow
that means you can marry nine we have to
stop and say okay what have other
scholars said about this right if
someone uses a hobby that's authentic
that totally goes against the position
of nine we said okay nine is not you
know if we see the promise hola Salaam
had nine but in a hadith he mentions
only four not to go beyond that right we
say okay we need the nine that was
specifically for the promise of a
lottery or something right that's what
we have to go through this academic
rigor and that's what's called each T
had that's academic exertion so if
someone was to say okay you know for
instance you know when it comes to
seeing the person that you want to
propose to there are differences of
opinion on what you can see in what you
cannot now is this is his opinion is
this is his interpretation valid that's
we have to see where he's come from
where exactly what exactly did he used
to say that and that's his method of
interpretation is it valid or not and it
depends on the issue and what he he uses
to validate their opinion as you guys
can see this is a very vast topic I just
gave you a little bit of a taste getting
you a little bit wet in the the water
tell us that people want to go deeper
into this how can they go ahead and oh
you got its resources WWD ENS hom go to
the Dean so no I mean I mean again again
if we want to study anything you know
you have to do exactly that you have to
study you have to go to the people of
knowledge you know not to say that this
is a religion of you know the people of
knowledge you you can never be one it's
a certain nationality no I mean when I
first was coming into Islam and I was
not a Muslim I walked into the mass here
with my San Diego Chargers Jersey man
and you know just came from a studio and
the guy with the Imam he said look you
can be better than ever
they say you can be better than me he
said it's about knowledge knowledge is
what increases your nobility in front of
a lot in amongst people it doesn't
matter where you from nationality does
that's totally irrelevant
same thing with knowledge of Islam if we
want to go four years ten years to get a
PhD in psychology PhD and to become a
doctor to become a lawyer to become
anything we have academic rigor in order
to even be considered to get those
letters behind me why Islam the most
noble of of any academic structure any
academic knowledge Islam it comes from
God why is it that we feel that we can
just go online press click and go to
share Google and think that we can
answer the questions to save the world
it's the most most noble no this is
Shutterfly let me shut it from my room
they said the nobility of your knowledge
depends on the nail building the ability
of what you are studying so if we were
studying about Allah and what he's
telling us in life via Quran via cinavia
everything else that branches from that
from faith hadith all those are Sciences
if we're studying that we have to do
exactly that
it's study it's not gonna be over a year
it's not gonna be over a seminar it's
gonna be over years on in right and then
all in with this statement of email
Missouri was who was a scholar of he-man
malik or the for men is the Malachy myth
happy was his scholar he said when
Rahman in the Joomla Joomla he said
whoever comes upon him when arrived is
arrived to knowledge all at one time
it'll leave him all at one time
verily knowledge comes with hadith and
hadith and oh one hadith another hadith
gradual nate day and night day and night
so that requires passion perseverance
discipline and most of all toe feed any
floss you have a website for new Muslims
yes yeah yeah I'm the lights called a
new UK in aw letter you wwk in aw later
you so people they have the basics of
Islam they do like we're working on some
other classes have like the ten hadith
that every new Muslim should know the
ten I add that every Muslim should know
what is in Iowa's hadeeth have seminars
with who that wants to learn how to
teach new Muslims we have something
called Eman plants and
the book that I wrote about you know
about five years ago talking about the
conditions of Lila law some scholars
mentioned there are seven conditions
right to heart and soul oh how does one
purify themselves the bare bone you know
an introduction the last chapters
introduction to Quran and some know what
is Quran and what does it mean in my
life what is my responsibility and what
is something I mean and give it and I
give an example of a hadith and the
relevance of how do you earning growing
every day don't stay at the white bill
keep growing and keep learning keep
expanding your mind we'll see you next
time subscribe if you haven't already
here at the Deen show to get our shows
every week peace be with you Salaam
alaikum alaikum
please subscribe to the dgo follow us on
our official Facebook and Twitter pages
in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below
[Music]